ja wir haben jetzt schon öfters jetzt
darüber gesprochen in vielen religionen
spielt er raus eine gewisse rolle
es wurde der karneval auch erwähnt als
ein gleich rituell rituelle
rauschzustand in einer gesellschaft
bestimmte tage die dafür reserviert
worden sind mich würde interessieren
herr schade da kann man eigentlich so
rituelle rauschzustände einfach von
kultur zu kultur transportieren und
vielleicht können wir das ein bisschen
deutlicher machen was ich meine an dem
alaska ritual dass sie mitgemacht haben
im rahmen einer feldstudie was ist also
dieser trank davon war schon die rede
zusammen gemixt aus café staude glaube
ich und eine liane kommt im
amazonasbecken vor und sie waren bei so
einem rausch gemeinsam gefeierten
rauschzustand dabei genau als forscher
und das hat mich im prinzip interessiert
warum so viele menschen ausgerechnet in
den amazonas reisen um da an solchen
ritualen statistischen ritualen mit
alaska teilzunehmen was die motivation
und die hoffnung letztlich ist von
menschen was sie sich dafür hoffen sind
eines nachlassens von beschwerden
vielleicht eine befreiung von sicht
erkrankungen depression und da bin ich
selber hin gereist und habe mir das vor
ort mal angesehen und es war für mich
sehr eindrücklich zu erleben dass da
eine ganze kultur um das wasser herum
entstanden ist eine indigene kultur die
diese medizin eigentlich fast schon als
sakrament verehrt und dann in
zeremoniellen settings eben feiert wo
sich menschen dann nachts treffen und
dann kollektiv eben dieses wasser
einnehmen dann heftige gefühle
hochkommen
teilweise müssen sie sich auch über
geben was sie dann als körperliche
reinigung beschreiben das ganze wird
begleitet von gesängen durch
medizinmänner und am morgen wird dann
die zeremonie aufgelöst viele teilnehmer
fühlen sich revitalisiert oder haben
einsichten bekommen in persönlicher
lebenszusammenhänge oder auch tiefe
spirituelle erfahrungen gemacht und
jetzt bieten sie sozusagen aber diese
substanz auch an oder sie machen studien
dazu im rahmen eben von
psychotherapeutischen settings also
meine frage wäre kann man denn nun diese
journalistische ritual in einer
gemeinschaft erlebt einfach nehmen und
ihren einzeln setting in der schweiz in
einem klinik kaum durchführen
als arzt ist meine primäre motivation
menschliches leiden zu lindern und ich
bin auf der suche nach neuen innovativen
therapien
das heißt wenn werkstoffe von alaska
tatsächlich therapeutisch wirksam sind
dann wäre es eigentlich unethisch diese
nicht auch im westen anzuwenden um
depressionen angststörungen
suchterkrankungen zu leiden
ich denke es macht wenig sinn oder eine
tradition aus einer fremden kultur eins
zu eins in unserer kultur zu verpflanzen
sondern es geht vielmehr um die frage
können wir hier im westen einen kontext
kreieren der für unsere menschen hier
verständlich ist und nützlich ist um die
nützlichen effekte von alaska in unserer
kultur vielleicht
auch zu wenden vielleicht kommen wir
trotzdem auf so eine idee zurück die wir
am anfang schon mal versprochen herzen
ging es nicht ursprünglich in diesen
wegen jetzt mal religiösen formen des
rausches darum die gemeinschaft zu
stärken und die verbundenheit gegen
aussen hin zu erleben mit gott mit der
natur vielleicht mit den tieren
währenddessen ist heute in vielen
rauschzuständen um den trip nach innen
geht sich selber nahe zu sein sein
eigenes bewusstsein zu erweitern
mir fällt ganz spontan ein wenn sie das
so beschreiben es gibt ja in clubs finde
ich mehr und mehr die unsitte muss man
sagen sich selbst und andere andere
leute während des rauschzustand es zu
filmen also um das dann irgendwie zu
posten oder oder was weiß ich was und
deshalb ist in guten klubs gibt es ja
ein smartphone verbot also man darf
einfach nicht mit dem smartphone
irgendwie so machen also was ich daran
so interessant finde ist ja dass im
moment des rausches wo es eigentlich
darum geht tatsächlich einfach mal sich
selber mal ganz kurz zu vergessen
und irgendwie auch zu gehen auch in
dieser gemeinschaft in mit der man da
vielleicht tanzt oder irgendwie in
gemeinsamen raus rauschzustand erlebt in
diesem in diesem klub mauern das
eigentlich verunmöglicht wird durch
diese reflexive distanz des des
smartphones das was wirklich extrem
erschwert in diesem zustand überhaupt
noch zu kommen
sie hat nur am anfang ihres gesprächs
darauf gesagt sie sind ein richtiger
protest an dass ihnen scheint wenn schon
raus wichtig zu sein irgendwie religiös
angebunden was wäre denn passiert der
unterschied wenn sie dieses alaska
ritual hören werden sie auch finden sich
in ja kollegen sozusagen können wir
ruhig hier auch mal durchführen
also ich bin erstmal milan scheint
längst scheider gas meinung wenn es um
die medizinische anwendbarkeit geht dann
müssen wir diese substanzen testen ob
sie tatsächlich einen medizinischen
nutzen haben und das passiert derzeit
das finde ich sehr sehr gute idee
erstmal nicht beschäftigt ja eher der
der rauschzustand außerhalb medizinische
anwendung
oder nicht nicht medizinische
anwendungen des rausches ansonsten und
da kommt mir natürlich schon der
eindruck dass gerade die psychedelic
adidas derzeit eine renaissance erleben
nicht nur in der psychiatrie sondern
auch in der gesellschaft zb in so einer
oscar zirkel dass das so eine form von
para spiritualität ist ja also wir haben
wir haben eine religiöse entkernen in
den letzten 30 40 50 jahren erfahren
aber die sehnsucht nach spirituelle
erfahrungen die ist natürlich geblieben
und die füllen wir jetzt auf unter
anderem bezeichnen zu können und ein
kollege der sich auch mit dem thema
beschäftigt hat mir erzählt dass
irgendwo in holland tausende von leuten
auf alaska zu den klängen einer
wunderbar und der wunderbaren welt der
amelie plötzlich auf den tripp gehen wo
ich denke wie pervertiert ist diese
kulturelle aneignung in dem moment in
meinen augen des awards gar aus dass ich
sie kurz fragen woher nehmen sie ihre
wertung was ist die grundlage dieser
wertung warum ist das passiert
naja ich glaube dass wir tatsächlich
eine kulturelle technik übertragen und
sie aber spirituell letztlich dadurch
entfernt haben da wo diese diese technik
angewendet wird dort gibt es einen
klaren kulturellen rahmen klaren
kulturellen umgang es gibt ein ritus in
denen das eingebettet ist und hier nimmt
man sich einfach einen kleinen teil raus
letztlich den rausch die die veränderung
des bewusstseins und macht die sozusagen
zu einem rein hedonistischen erlebnis
und das finde ich das finde ich erstmal
bemerkenswert die wertung
ja sie haben die wertung herausgehört
ich finde es aber auch irgendwie in
gewisser weise
sie haben vorhin lachen wissen ja ich
bin okay ist
und trotzdem habe ich ja sehr
protestantische züge erlebt also ich
finde es nicht so schlimm wenn man sich
jetzt eine kultur von irgendwo aneignet
und daran spaß hat es ich finde es
gefährlicher die hoffnung die daran
kriegt also ich habe im freundeskreis
leute die gehen vor zwei wochen nach
südamerika gibt sich der den teheran
fühlen sich schlecht damit sie sich gut
fühlen können sehr zynisch sehr
protestantisch und kommen zurück und
haben diese tiefe erfahrung und diese
tiefen weisheiten und da geht es nicht
um medizinische anwendung oder darum
therapeutisches selbstmedikation da geht
es wirklich um diese spirituelle suche
und man kann das nach sonnenuntergang
bildern auf instagram ausformuliert
sehen und es ist eigentlich meistens
ziemlich banale sorry bullshit aber
verbunden mit dieser tiefen emotionen
die die ihm raus erlebt wurde wird es
plötzlich wichtig nun für einen
spirituellen weg denke ich nicht dass es
eine abkürzung gibt und da bin ich
wieder da das ist wenn jemand sein leben
lang so viel meditation verschiedenster
vorne macht und ab und zu ein clips von
etwas anderem erreicht hat das wirklich
überzeugt mich das wenn ich in zwei
wochen urlaub irgendwo kombiniert mit
badestrand vielleicht noch buche und
dann denke ich komme als weiser mensch
zurück
dann denke ich dass es ein bisschen
beschiss herr schneider gar sie sind ja
auch jemand der sich sehr gut auskennt
mit achtsamkeit meditation sie haben
auch das erforscht beherrschen das
selber auch auf eine art 10
buddhistische weltlich gewendete
meditationsform und auch da gibt es
studien wo sie zeigen konnten wenn man
das kombiniert mit psychedelischen
substanzen dann kommt man tiefer in die
meditation in die ruhe in diese stille
reihen ist das zutreffen was jetzt herr
ra wie sagt ist das ein bisschen so eine
abkürzung die auch hohl wirken kann oder
würden sie sagen
das ist einfach nur eine potenzierung
des ganzen lasst uns doch das einfach
kombinieren
ich glaube man muss unterscheiden
zwischen achtsamkeit als bewusstseins
technik und achtsamkeit als eine form
von spiritualität weil man dann andere
wirklichkeiten oder wo man gewisse
sehnsüchte oder bedürfnisse letztlich
damit befriedigt und was mich primär
interessiert ist aus achtsamkeit aus
bewusstseins technik das heißt wie gehe
ich mit meinem bewusstsein so um dass
sich beispielsweise unangenehme gefühle
schmerzlich gefühle alles was das leben
zu bieten hat auch integrieren kann
statt es letztlich aus meinem
bewusstsein wegzudrängen indem ich eben
in irgendwelche spirituellen
glaubensrichtungen mich dann hin bewegen
was anderes was interessant ist in dem
zusammenhang ist das phänomen der selbst
transzendenz also die fähigkeit
letztlich dass ich bewusstsein
aufzulösen in was größeres einzugehen
und da glaube ich das ist ein phänomen
was in vielen letztlich rausch
erfahrungen drin steckt und dass ich
nicht nur auf meditation beschränkt
sondern befinden das eben auch in der
psychedelische erfahrung oder in anderen
gipfel erlebnissen abgang maslow hat das
pik experience is genannt und die frage
die mich als wissenschaftler beschäftigt
ist welche rolle oder welche funktion
haben diese peak experience können diese
pick experience letztlich zu einem
perspektivenwechsel beitragen oder zur
gesundheitsförderung oder persönlichen
weiterentwicklung eines menschen
unabhängig davon was sich dahinter noch
versteckt oder warten sie ich würde
gerne einen letzten punkt noch aufnehmen
den sie aufgebracht haben darauf lassen
wir sie haben gesagt es gibt
verschiedene gründe weswegen wir
vielleicht den raussuchen könnten
einer könnte auch sein dass wir uns
fürchten vor den tod das ist war teil
des mager quarks dass wir alle sterben
müssen ist eigentlich furchtbar und
vorhin wurde so wunderschön geschrieben
die eigentlich die meditation diese
mystic einen vorlaufen zum tode ist ein
stück weit ein
üben dass sich lösen vom eigenen ich und
tatsächlich hat die meditation immer
auch dieses moment betont und
interessanterweise hat michael tollen
diesen vorschlag in seinem buch ganz
stark dass er sagt lasst uns in der
palliativmedizin als in der betreuung
von schwerkranken sterbenden menschen
auch stärker wieder mit psychedelic
arbeiten um diese angst vor dem tod
überwinden zu können um erfahrungen zu
ermöglichen die nahe sind am tod
vielleicht ganz kurz noch ist das eine
idee der sie sich anschließen können für
die sie sich erwärmen können
oder gilt es das einfach auszuhalten die
ich angst erklärte nun es gibt sehr gute
studiendaten dazu dazu dass gerade bei
erkrankungen die im tod unmittelbar mit
den truppen bedroht sind
angstzustände durch solche substanzen
stark gemildert werden können warum auch
immer ob da ein spirituelles erlebnis
dahinter stehen zweimal entwischte sehen
sie das scheint ja ich denke jede raus
erfahrung ist gewissermaßen eine
simulation oder eines sterbeprozess ist
also die person gibt eigentlich in dem
moment oder er fährt einen ähnlichen
prozess den sie vielleicht einen
fertigen sie stirbt und zurück zu kommen
diesen prozess durchgemacht zu haben
kann letztlich auch den respekt die
angst die haltung sowohl dem tod aber
auch dem leben gegenüber fremden denkt
übrigens eine sehr schöne geschichte
dazu ist ja odysseus homers odyssee der
der diese irrfahrt macht bekanntermaßen
und dann irgendwann an der insel vorbei
kommt wo die sirenen leben und diese
vogel ähnlichen wesen und es ist
vollkommen klar wenn er sich jetzt
diesen gesang einfach so ausliefert dann
wird er sterben wir alle seeleute vorher
auch er wird diesen dieser verlockung
erliegen er wird sterben und deshalb
wendet er den berühmten trick an weil er
zuvor gewarnt wurde durch türke durch
die göttin und er lässt seinen seeleuten
die ohren verstopfen lässt sich von den
seeleuten wiederum an einen mast binden
lässt sich selbst nicht die ohren
verstopfen weil er den gesang genießen
möchte aber er ist am macht gefesselt
und kann eben nicht seinem drang seinem
trieb gehorchen und zu diesen vogel
ähnliche wesen wollen und und das ist
glaube ich in dieser geschichte steckt
wahnsinnig viel drin also einmal die die
todesnähe des genießens es gibt bei
freud ja auch den todestrieb also ich
glaube dass tatsächlich auch diese die
sehnsucht danach diese grundspannung des
lebens einfach aufzulösen
es ist einfach auch anstrengend zu leben
so dass das dass das genießen das dass
das natürlich eine weise ist und dass
aber gerade für uns moderne subjekte ist
einfach natürlich in der aufgabe ist die
kontrolle zu behalten und den genuss
genauso weit an sich ranzulassen dass
ich hier noch goutieren kann aber eben
nicht erliegen
was sind wir wieder bei der ambivalenz
und wir sind am ende unserer sendung